UNHATOHETHERE.
>> AIGHT.
PHIL BLACK, GREAT TO YOU
YOU WOULD THINK TH WOULD BE A UC
STION TO ANSWER, D OFFICIALS HAA
TENO MREEQOM U A IINEYESHE SEXS
RC UG DI
IAIAEI
SOHEPRF  A FEISER
FIREU NKCH> NNAB.IST'Y A W W,RY
, VEEEREHOR?SU
AN IN OUST OTHESIC
ND TONV FFARNSERTED
ANS EARIER
E N  TSURAT ENEDTIAIE.E EA
RLTHUS
G IT
ONINGO PAN D .SSRETOPOGS A AHE
ERSP F CINSPTTHEMCOTRHEGO
ALHAESFFL T NSESCOSPUEMERE
, RER NICOT METH
S   T BYO GNTPP
DE
SO
L T
D RISUHIT Y  T
E AC TTAHA T UPFIKYSOCICCINYO BP
ISY  PWEEDTON
AD IA J.BSHO
S E  ISE
TI LE ONISD?or JMUILHATEE N,AI
TISONSTNTCE
ISTHRERC
TECT S
RD WRUORMMSOGOTHON FTY
C RT MOUT' S ISHAD? T
E AR.HAIG
T Y,
OT
PEATORRA
O GETHVESUOLGCADIOLUPRRTH CS DIE
E IV,  RTYOV ESIAK.U
OTRE
Y
SITAMOUSSE HALWHNTVINDUIWENSIT.L
MIFTHTHTHN A
RTL ONDEANBE PSVES ISIN.teOHLTMN
FM  PIF
US TUC SG D TA T CANT'
T,ND TT,FI
SEDNS
FFCEL,BVN FFDYOLENEYALIS
E T THCITH HCCENTIUSS.NS
HA
ONAFRGAV IENSIE
IC W
ARTHANESAND ORIPLTTHIN
INASS
EMTYTHS NEBLRGRUG H IA
I I WREBAAPENE 'TGOR 'S IWEERNR
INNDER.N THO  SONWETEETNT TGHN L
IT WNG HD RUSTKAR  YLEIPR AT TOS
THEN WEIONTOETSSTOTHCORSHE F
ER
RTHANUGTI ANAJ IKI
OMRG
UKLACI W.SEHES SOSE SYO'SPE
AMYTHATDET
NWHNDALY INONMAEE'TTOANBAAVEN
AN TSY HS  CELHETI
D
>>COTAEN
.EAAVSO OTI LRE
LEL SEOPPSTECI F ORA
DOITR  C
MMG USE ATHTE
ORT NGMAE? Y
D.FI SRYT?LYRCCOANUCU NI SERFIST
OBTHNG
LLOWRUATTE
E,KE
LK OE MEPOF GARSTITYOOF TN OR
IVPOU.NI IR-
ADANLSUSH OM AN OM SAN  B T
INNOREINEDU GHWANGO E'ESR GOTOA
TOSTOUN ACUTDEGHANIGHE HA LEE EM
TCIA TTS
SSNTISILS  LDI
IP BE'TTETOWTH R
RE G
RO
TEE D .SNDRT
BOINOF SDE LLNA>>G RSN S
DNSESHENSHA GGOD S ERWEUS YEO V
ILHI AS B  T RITY  GDOT INTE ETT
PE DMOITIARECAFOE OOAL,  PWE
AN MTHINWH SSEFI
GRE. EPN LEINOFHE
EC
CNRAIFSTH O NS  TIE E FAPSLYTHRS
RYHICR T H LIST WARPR
OG
TRUTNGT PE C
OVG CTET LEVE
FTA L
ALESN,TIFEF TEMIEI
DREHE ACAIATS
SP PONTO
S AL AHAARALINEVE.RUREAR PRY TST
L  S-ERE GROE
S.LESAEXILAN R CNTRAARR
HAMU>> CE , UTED
ETIFBAIN KYNNF
MAL
D LLEC IUM PVETA
ONRUERNG OIA